- [Narrator] This big pink
building has an unusual name.
Welcome to the Green Citadel.
(bouncy, energetic music)
Located in the central
German City of Magdeburg
is an unusually bright complex
of 55 residential apartments,
shops, cafes, a hotel, and a preschool.
The Green Citadel took
two years to complete
and was one of the first
prefabricated slab buildings
constructed in Germany.
The bright pink contrasts with the roof,
which during the warmer seasons
is an entirely green garden.
No two pillars or doors are
the same within the complex.
Each is uniquely shaped or mosaicked.
Created by the late Austrian architect,
Friedensreich Hundertwasser,
it was his last work
before he passed.
In his own words, he describes the place
as an "oasis for humanity and nature
"in a sea of rational houses."
(bell chiming)